we saw a great potential there for uh
automation
when saying automation i mean not only
easy drag and drop
but no drag and drop at all and no costs
just just small small some tunings after
uh algorith did their job
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctek
my next guest is from armenia and is the
co-founder of cto of ten web
meet tigranozarian co-founder and ceo of
ten web io
with a strong background in science and
technology tigran has vast hands-on
experience in software development
machine learning and bringing automation
into web development
technologies that can help millions of
engineers and designers
focus on truly creative and important
elements and leave routine
and time-consuming tasks to algorithms
he is passionate
about building a strong company culture
that turns great ideas into powerful
technological achievements
and at the same time empathizes with the
community
with the vision of automation he puts
his best to lead 10 webs team of 70
professionals on the way to become a
unicorn
igor nazarian welcome to 20 minute
leaders all the way from armenia
how are you doing hi michael
thank you very much for your invitation
it's my pleasure to be here your guest
i'm fine very happy to be here thank you
very very much for being here
i believe you're my first guest from
armenia this is really exciting i'm get
i'm becoming global i feel it and i'm
excited about it
i'm excited to talk about about your
journey you know both in in academia
from there
but also with what you're doing with 10
web dot io
and bringing ai automation to web
development
leading over 70 engineers and then you
know i've been
the world of engineering has changed a
lot
in the last decade or so particularly in
the last few years
uh both in terms of outsourcing but also
in terms of
you know just the the great engineering
work that is being done across the world
in all sorts of places
and i'm excited to talk about both the
the armenian tech ecosystem that you're
part of
but also your work outside of armenia
with your clients and and
a little bit about your journey so
before we even start with that
i have to hear the story about you
teaching
high school or physics and then him
coming back to give you feedback from a
yc
tell me a little bit about it
that's interesting actually 10 years ago
i was teaching
at high school physics and astronomy to
talented students and i really enjoyed
that work and i always enjoyed teaching
students and science because i was also
doing my phd then and
it was good time but it turns out that
suddenly or maybe not so suddenly i came
to industry
although to be honest during my student
years
when i was studying physics uh
as many of uh physics and tech students
i was freelancing sometimes and we are
doing some
site building and some coding and
so at some point in my life i came back
to that
from academia to the industry
amazing tell me a little bit about you
know your experience with academia
you're talking about physics and
astrophysics you're actually i believe
you did your your phd in astronomy and
astrophysics
did you did you want to be you know an
astronomer or an astrophysicist
was this sort of the the trajectory that
you were on
i can say yes because from like
high school years i was interested in
physics and astronomy and generally
science and it was quite a natural path
in my life that i went to
study physics at the university then i
did my phd
and a lot of people like me were going
that path
and i really enjoyed it and it was
really cool because
uh from childhood i was interested in
uh research and uh perhaps this is kind
of a
way of thinking then when you wanna
explore the world around you and
it was quite natural for me
so i went to astrophysics and
we're studying extra galactic constant
physics or particularly
galaxies and how they collide with each
other and
stars are forming being formed there
wonderful and so fast forward a little
bit you
you go into the world of engineering and
today
you're leading over seven engineers what
what happened what was the shift and and
i'd love to also hear a little bit about
the the armenian tech ecosystem that
that
you know you grew up in right because
you did your phd in armenia and
you transitioned into tech also there
tell me a little bit about
what's happening in the tech ecosystem
and how you found your place within that
yeah that's great question and i think
uh to some extent
we can apply to other countries as well
we see a lot of people going from
academia to industry
and i think generally that academia has
a kind of crisis there
because too many people are doing phds
but there are too
few positions and yeah a lot of people
end up being going to software
development or
machine learning or kind of engineering
and in armenia we have a
emerging i would say ecosystem of
startups and i.t
community which grows pretty fast with
20 a year over year growth
so it's a tremendous country and i think
more than 20 000 people or even more are
involved in this sector of economics the
i.t so i would compare perhaps this
to what was in israel perhaps uh
20 or 30 years ago and so
well now it's completely different
picture yeah
are you seeing more people you know in
engineering positions
do you see more entrepreneurs coming out
of romania what's what's actually been
happening there
we see people
not only creating technologies and doing
some coding
it was like 10 years ago mostly
uh there back then more companies were
doing outsourcing but now we can see
more and more companies creating their
own products and
companies which are going global right
from the start so
they have global direction
they start from being just global
company they focus on global customers
and this enables fast growth for that
because if you have small
in a small country with several million
people you cannot focus
on any internal market uh for
most of uh it companies and it's it's
actually
benefit when you start global and not
switch to global after some
time so fast forward to 10web.io
co-founder today's ceo more than seven
engineers
what is it what is ten web io what do
you do there yeah
this is automated wordpress platform we
started to build four years ago in 2017
uh it's live you can try how it works
there are few camp components there
including hosting
site building with artificial
intelligence automatic optimization and
migration
and maintenance or management of
websites
so this is whole platform for people who
are creating
and websites from for themselves and
also for people whose
job is to create websites for others
like agencies and freelancers
so take me back a little bit wordpress
has been around for a long time and we
have emerging
no code tools or little code tools like
wix and and others yeah what is the pain
that you're observing a few years ago
when you start to turn web io
what is the you know the big pain point
that you realize that it says
wow like we we have a gap here that we
can use ai automations for migrations
and for
for better website building experiences
yeah that's great great question we see
a lot of
low code or no code site builders
popping up now but wordpress was created
around 15 years ago and to some extent
it solved the problem of no coding or
less coding that back then there was no
such hybrid no code
but and when we started the working
uh great company uh first we did we
created the plugins we were
doing plugins development for wordpress
and that base
a lot of customers around the million of
customers and our plugins were popular
and they are popular up to now
but we saw that um there is a kind of
gap
in user experience with wordpress
although wordpress is really very
powerful
it's flexible it's open source and has
all these benefits
but but compared to other platforms like
vix or webflow
it's a little bit complicated and
it's also fragmented because wordpress
is
one part and plugins each for each
plugin you find your
different vendor you get hosting for
third-party vendor etc
so there is a lot of stuff to do
manually to combine all them to set up
them
and just to create a site building
experience uh it's it's it's
to some extent it's automated with drag
and drop side pillars like alameda which
uh really cool uh israel company and
there are others like elementor like
their categories side builder plugins
but we see that this work is being done
manually
so we saw a great potential there for uh
automation
when saying automation i mean not only
easy drag and draw
but no drag and drop at all and no cost
just just small small some tunings after
algorithms did their job
and we think the automation is the
future of web development
kind of holy grail of web development
right so i'm trying to picture you know
what circumstances could allow you to
understand this pain point and is it
safe to assume that
part of the reason why you were able to
get exposed to
a lot of this work that could be
automated and could be improved
and again not in the automation in the
sense of just making it easier but
really making it a bit
making a big difference is it because
there are quite a few people around your
ecosystem that
are creating websites that are using
wordpress
i i do know that you know a lot of
places like armenia are also well known
for their great
outsourcing capabilities that have these
really great engineers that can
do really magic with with sites like
wordpress right
yeah yeah i would say also that but we
saw that
like uh by
taking a look at our customers
experiences
with uh plugging customers and not only
our
millions of people using plugins and
we're doing wordpress development and
this is mostly
manual work taking a lot of time and
yeah we saw during this six
or more years of our experience that we
can do something there
and the automation should be not only
kind of a
single service but be a part of
a whole platform and to provide holistic
experience this is what wordpress also
misses
right today you are
leading over seven engineers what is
sort of the the grand vision
of what you're building you know when
you wake up and you say
ten web io as the ceo as the co-founder
what where where is this going what is
the grand
vision here yeah
i would say this is the same automation
but we think
of a few a few years
ahead press in the future building
websites to be as
easy as just drinking a cup of coffee
uh you you do nothing you just enable
you it works you just enable
with kind of some small kind of input
what you wanna approximately uh because
very often we wanna have
like websites or we can we're gonna
describe this uh
in uh when talking to each other yes
like i wanna have
single landing page one contact page one
page about
the company with few sections and in
these
colors and like this and
we think that this is uh
first every person should be able to
create website
and uh we think that also open source
is a crucial point there website should
be open source and not logged in
platforms
where from which you cannot export your
data
or you have some limitations and where
are most of the clients coming from so
most of the people that you're working
with
where where geographically are they from
uh they're quite dispersed across the
world we will
focus on the u.s customers but it
doesn't work that way
we focus on u.s customers but a lot of
people from europe from
uh asia south america comic
are there interesting insights that you
have from working with
i'm guessing a lot of customers uh that
that as you do this at scale do you
notice any patterns
either in the efficiency of the work or
things that really make a difference
in whether a project will be successful
or not because
like you're mentioning a big trend that
we have not only you know outsourcing is
just
the big buzzword or time for this but
it's really the idea
that today almost every person wants a
website every business definitely needs
a website
and the ability for every person who
needs a website to build a website is
very limited
and and there you have you know
phenomenal tools like a company like
tenure bio that can help improve that
what what interesting things have you
been observing
perhaps i would mention the increasing
complexity of
websites and web applications
even browsers 30 years ago
web pages were just starting documents
with a kind of markup which was semantic
but now we see that it's not kind of
document but it's all application inside
single
uh web page and they are going extremely
complex
and uh a lot of integrations we see
with third-party services with back-end
with a lot of
like technology stack is really complex
so um the
learning curve for web development is
going like this
now and we see the
two different kind of front-end
development back-end development
separation of
areas of expertise so
that's uh that was not perhaps what
webb was being
thought about uh several decades ago now
it's quite difficult to create a website
and to have a good production website i
mean to optimize it
to take care about search engine
optimization
payments into a lot of integrations yeah
we want to make people's experience as
smooth and easy as possible with all
this complexity
and so i'm guessing that a big part of
dealing with this complexity
a big challenge that is being introduced
here is the ability to be
updated with what's happening every day
you have new plugins every day you have
new integrations every day
you know even shifting in trends in what
customers are asking for
what types of features they want and all
of a sudden you see
somebody has a feature you want that
same feature how do you maintain
you know the high professionalism of a
group
that needs to be knowledgeable and be
efficient
and and produce quickly
yeah that that's really uh
hard question first thing you cannot do
it law
you need to share this and ownership of
being
up to date with the team so every person
in the team should be
have a responsibility uh to be up to
date and to share
the new knowledge with others and this
is what we do
we have several processes internally
when engineers discuss
with each other new technologies they
share their experience
across teams not only in a single team
and i think this is a crucial part of
having good engineering team and we have
such
engineering team i'm proud of them
that's amazing and so now you're 70
people
and you know i'm asking now about you
tigran you're
an astrophysicist in a by training
not just a with a bachelor's or master's
but with a phd
you're obviously a phenomenal thinker
and a great entrepreneur
if you think about your trajectory are
you surprised at
where you are today whether it's in
terms of
you know the the things you're working
on or the or the place that you're at
is anything surprising to you about the
journey that you're on
yes i would never imagine even five
years ago
to do the job i'm doing right now
but uh i'm open to challenge myself
and i'm don't afraid to go out of my
comfort zone
and the eternal curiosity i have
it's uh it's it's something internal it
i have this such curiosity in every
field
a few years ago i had it more in the
science than in engineering and now in
business
and yeah we have in such we live in such
a
unique times that when things are
changing very fast so
we we need to face that challenge and be
ready to challenge ourselves and to
learn
uh every day i love it degran thank you
so much for joining me all the way from
armenia i have a few last questions for
you if you're ready
yep okay a number one
um favorite subject in middle school or
high school
i'm guessing it's physics but i may be
wrong
and not only i was i really liked
geography
as well geography what was it about
geography that you liked
i i like imagining how
people are living across the globe how
the diverse
are plotted and the societies and
nature is in the world wonderful
and one of your role models somebody
that inspires you
that's hard question for me perhaps not
for others but i i never thought about
that
as because things change a lot so fast
so i haven't never have time to think
about that
and i think even that the role model
right now if i
think about that such person may change
very fast
so i just i just want to have take the
best from
uh whoever whomever i can
i love it and three words that you would
use to describe yourself
uh flexible reasonable
and caring flexible
reasonable and caring eh sounds like a
phenomenal
a combination degron thank you so much
for
joining me all the way from armenia i
really appreciate it best of luck with
10web io
i'm really happy we made this work and
and i'm really excited to share this
with everybody and until then you know
stay safe and stay healthy
and i look forward to one day meeting in
person either in israel in armenia in
the us wherever it may be
thank you very much michael thank you
take care
you